جلبت العاصفة دينيس رياحًا
شديدة العاصفة ومستويات هائلة من الأمطار إلى المملكة المتحدة في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، حيث غمرت الشوارع
والمستنقعات الداخلية ، وفي بعض أجزاء البلاد ،
من المحتمل أن تزداد سوءًا ، حيث
ضربت العاصفة المميتة الساحل البريطاني
بينما أجبرت المزيد من
الناس على ذلك.  الفرار إلى الأراضي المرتفعة حيث
فاضت الأنهار على ضفافها ، وكان
أسوأ الفيضانات في جنوب غرب إنجلترا
وفي ويلز حيث لجأت السلطات من
باب إلى باب مع القوارب واستخدمت
المروحيات في عمليات الإنقاذ يوم
الأحد ، تسببت عاصفة دينيس في
عدد قياسي من التحذيرات من الفيضانات و  جلبت التنبيهات في
إنجلترا ما يقرب من 600 طقس يوم الثلاثاء
فترة راحة ترحيبية للعديد من
المناطق حيث انحسرت مياه الفيضانات تاركةً
فوضى موحلة في الشوارع ولكن
مشكلة أكبر بكثير داخل المنازل ،
فقد تلاشى جميع الأثاث جميع السجاد الأرضي
والكهرباء والغاز كل شيء دمر
جميع المنازل دمرت جميعها  من
هطول الأمطار على رأس العاصفة التي هطلت بها كيرا
قبل أسبوع واحد فقط في شمال
إنجلترا كان دينيس آخر شيء  لقد
احتاجت ey بشكل جيد إلى تحسن الوضع في
بعض المجتمعات في أماكن أخرى ، فقد يستمر الأمر في
التفاقم مع استمرار ارتفاع مستويات الأنهار
مما أدى إلى تحذيرات من الفيضانات التي تشكل
خطرًا على الحياة وتوقع حدوث
المزيد من الأمطار الغزيرة هذا الأسبوع Scott
McLean CNN London